تصعيد غير مسبوق تشهده الحرب في اوكرانيا
بعد ان تجاوزت الضربات الاوكرانيه خط
بوتين الاحمر ووصلت بضوء امريكي اخضر الى
قلب روسيا
استراتيجيه جديده حرر فيها البنتاجون يدك
لاول مره وفقا لمجله ذا تايمز البريطانيه
اوكرانيا بمساعده صور الاقمار الاصطناعيه
الامريكيه تمكنت من تنفيذ هجوم جريء على
الاراضي الروسيه مستهدفه قاعدتين عسكريتين
على بعد مئات الاميال من موسكو احدها
استهدف منطقه سلطوف والاخر ضرب ريازان هذا
تاييد الامريكي الجديد لهجمات اوكرانيه في
العمق الروسي يمثل تطورا مهما في الحرب
المستمره منذ تسعه اشهر حسبنا ذكرت مجله
التايمز وسط توقعات بان تزود واشنطير
باسلحه اضافيه بعيده المدى
امريكا والتي كانت في السابق تخشى من رد
موسكو الغاضب حاله استهدافكياب الاراضي
الروسيه يبدو انها غيرت موقفها
مقلله من قيمه اي هجوم انتقام روسي حتى
وان كان نوويه
[موسيقى]
موافقه البنتاج على شان هجمات اوكرانيه في
العمق الروسي جاءت بشرط ان تمتنع اوكرانيا
عن ضرب اهداف مدنيه
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا حتى هذه اللحظه ما زالت حريصه
على استخدام طائراتها المسيره الخاص بعيدا
عن اللجوء الى اسلحه الدعم الامريكيه
لتنفيذ الضربات داخل روسيا
امر ربما يتغير وقد يدفع البنتاج لمراجعه
تقييمه لتهديدات العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
في اوكرانيا مره اخرى